[Music]
it's alright so this week we got cash
reward and treats he'll self Oh sounds
good to me
I want a cash reward but not for
anything like I just get rewarded for
being a lot and then you treat yourself
with right
isn't that my job I don't get any of
them now let's give you a cash reward
what when was the last cash you already
gave me uh yesterday what was it
how much cash all right three bucks
[ __ ] three bucks sounds good to me
are you a hamburger there's this 18 year
old named Tyler in Sacramento are shady
complete opposite oh that's good boy ngo
he was passing around flyers for his
uncle's pest control company in this
neighborhood where he came across a
wallet that had $1500 cash in it dang on
the driveway of this home he was going
to the strip club whoever owned it yeah
no well it turns out that the rent money
dude in cash who pays rent in cash
drug dealers well yeah then was cast in
the wallet what kind of wallet to hold
so many bills all these hundreds agents
love to hold cash they don't believe in
banks do you hold cash I'm not that
Asian they're saying that they had cash
because they were planning a party or
they were planning to throw a party and
that's the reason why they had so much
cash in their wallets sure
so when Tyler came across the wallet he
went up to the home and he was ringing
the doorbell trying to see if anyone was
home but Melissa she did see him
approach to the home but she didn't
answer the door shoes and answer the
door to strangers so then you can see
Tyler go up to a surveillance camera in
the front door and like show the camera
like hey here's a wallet and he flips it
over you can see the cash there he's
just like here it is I mean he he leaves
it on the front door what a good Samaria
and he walks away and so Melissa is just
saying she posted this on her Facebook
and look like this so I thought this guy
was gonna break into my house but he
ended up giving me money Wow
a good day yeah she ends up singing god
bless this young man's heart my husband
dropped his wallet with hundreds of
dollars and all his credit cards on in
our driveway and this gentleman picked
it up and left it at our doorstep after
waiting for a few minutes because I
wouldn't open the door parentheses for
strangers I later found him thanked him
and rewarded him for his kind gesture it
said that I didn't trust him to open my
door he was just doing a good deed sadly
this is the world we live in today we
hear so many terrible news and barely
any good I think we all need to be
reminded that there are still good
people out there his act of kindness
cannot go unrecognized Thank You Tyler
please share and she ended up giving him
a hundred and fifty dollars nice Wow
yeah percent finder's fee
it follows him all his life I would have
been out why I should have kept the
1,500 you're gonna give me fifth a
hundred fifty bucks I mean was he
supposed to go I would have gave I want
to get I'm just saying I would have gave
him like five hundred bucks
oh my mom always heard of it and you
know why it's because I would have had
zero but this purchased expecting less
out of society like I don't expect the
money back I think if I lost it someone
would it took it maybe threw the wallet
back at me and your credit cards yeah
and I probably be lucky just to get my
IV or something but then I see it as
this I [ __ ] up I lost it somewhere I
was being careless it's my
responsibility to get keep my [ __ ]
together and I would have lost the money
anyway so thanks like for bringing it
back I blame it on the basketball short
company no more the basketball shorts
company should [ __ ] pay Tyler the
money guarantee you he was wearing
basketball shorts or sweats her husband
yeah fell out of this popular Russell
Swift's [ __ ] they got the shittiest
pockets and I still wouldn't get them
filing it out when you do you buy
design our fleet shorts falls out all
the time I love those flea shorts I know
they're comfortable we have like the
casual line and right now where I have
to find out hey come out with more
colorways want more shorts and then we
do like our sports performance ones and
those are the ones that we consider a
lot more to it but for sports
performance we don't really considered
wallets like we do have stuff for like
ID and [ __ ] like that but yeah not
wallets but we do consider it so what
about yeah yes a biscuit he went viral
cuz he was saying like that's sad
exactly he was like this is so crazy I'm
getting so much exposure or something
that everybody should do yeah my mom did
this really good and I think my mom got
this from her mom but my mom did a
really good job of scaring me and saying
any time you steal and I've only stolen
like once or twice like my whole life
but she's like any time you steal you're
gonna lose something of equal or more or
greater value of what you stole and that
should always scared me because the last
time I did steal I forgot what I lost
but it was something oh my dad's camera
dude I was taking photography and he had
like the old school like film cameras
and someone stole that for me and I'm
like oh my mom was right
you started death Kevin no I didn't
steal my dad's camera I was borrowing it
for borrow what can I say baro baro baro
he is following following it for for a
photo class I was taking on but yet like
it was an expensive camera and then they
stole it from me why cuz you stole
someone else's camera oh no no no I know
I stole something right but I think the
time was just like coincidental that
karma thing yeah and then like like soon
after something got stolen from me
that's like a packet of sharpies and
then someone stole your uh for her
eyebrow couldn't do my eyebrows
[Laughter]
of all things to say [ __ ] sharpies
they're one of the most utilized markers
on this earth yeah whatever
wait a minute X whoa yeah that's dope so
that means all I gotta do to get my
heart stolen is if I steal someone
else's heart yep you're wack stole
someone's heart and it as a human and
what's gone any fool other pages got me
good I really hope that one of our
viewers is really like they're keeping
track of all your things
shot us to James Rodolfo he might do it
he actually takes the time to read like
watch every single video and he makes
dope ass compilations and there's
another one - [ __ ] I forgot the name
just can you replay oh yeah just getting
replayed just kidding see you guys
thanks for watching us yeah I think it's
a Qi rag Qi Chir AG that's his channel
no but have you ever done any good deeds
like this that's not good D that's a
normal it's a normal human being yeah if
it was just money I would get it he
found it on the ground you don't know
where it came while it did have actually
he's on their driveway he doesn't live
there you couldn't simply walk away no
here's the thing I found I found money
on the ground before in front of a place
um I told the nearest adult she was like
oh yeah that's my money thank you so
much [ __ ] locked again she gave me a
dollar out of it then I went around the
corner and it was coming back hearing
her laughing
I had was not her money and she tricked
me so if it was just money I would keep
it depending on how deep into the
driveway it was yeah but the fact that
it was in a wallet how deep does it have
a I know what if it's where you would
pull into turn around and leave
yeah that's my mm-hmm if it's abide yeah
by the oil stay where the host is
probably your money oh my proximity is
longer if it's on the diving board of
the pool
that's still my money if it's on the
[ __ ] swing set and I see a fat stack
of cash that's my money I'm coming over
the fence to go get my money yeah it was
in the wallet is that if it's behind the
window if it's in doing pocket but his
hand is in front of him just kidding I'm
not a thief
no all the money I've ever stolen no I
was just on the sidewalk like it wasn't
on anyone's property or anything I think
I fell in like 20 blocks on my school
field once and I was like this is like
$1,000 but it is you know the other day
I resisted to pick up a dollar
damn you ballin like that dude I said
like I'm changed because I was jogging
right I was running to barbell and I saw
a nice crisp dollar on the sidewalk and
as I saw that [ __ ]
I was it turned slow-motion for me I was
looking at it and I'm all like I am NOT
a Scrooge I am a Scrooge Scrooge McDuck
he's a penny pincher but you talk about
it like it was a penny on the floor I
would have you're giving me flashbacks
right now like I'm starting to feel
really guilty yeah like no you're right
like I just always picked the pennies
quarters whatever it was like I picked
up change like it was a [ __ ] billion
dollars so I was like I'm not gonna bend
over and be like that no more I am too
proud
but till this day I regret that
No why did I do that I don't even know
you know what I think whenever I see
bills like that or the very few times I
have seen bills like that I always think
like is this a prank like someone has
like a fishing wire they're gonna pull
it away from me so I I kind of like half
reach before X don't even reach it
step on it first yeah and then look
around yeah don't look at it just and
then slowly reach down like you're gonna
tie your shoelaces in that's smarter
because I have reach to see if anyone
who react no one does
I just pictured a bump picking it up
with three teeth going so I was like I
just imagined this happy as dudes and I
was like you know what this dollar is
gonna make somebody else way more happy
than me so I just imagined this guy like
in my homeless Kingdom just [ __ ]
dancing like one well our next story
speaking of dollars and money there was
this cute ass dog that she hoards money
and she why is that cute that she's
[ __ ] stealing it's because she uses
it to pay for treats
she is a smart dog to know the barter
wait does the dog get allowance so what
happened was when this dog was a puppy
her owner cuz she works at a restaurant
so she would be counting tips and she
would grab one of the dollar bills and
then in order for the owner to get the
bill back and so she wouldn't chew it up
or swallow it she would bribe her with
the treat so then she kind of like
unintentionally conditioned her to like
to know that money in exchange for money
you'll get a treat so she's an
extortionist no she's a consumer no she
stole the money you want it back in
there she's paying for treats with it
your money
she's a kidnapper that's what she all
treats [ __ ] yeah yes sir her
owner Kathy says that whenever she hears
whenever Holly here's Kathy counting
money she immediately runs to to her and
like she will not stop bugging her and
so Cassie gives her a dollar
and then she'll leave her alone so that
she saved the money now
yeah she actually has a big pile of cash
oh yeah do these like puffy eyes and so
she gets a dollar bill but she has two
little piggy banks here that is her
money and so I'm like what the owners do
it like they'll put all the money in the
jar and then whenever she bugs them for
another dollar bill there go they'll go
into her jar and then give her money
from there cuz she doesn't know where it
comes from because I feel like these
photos could be staged I don't know this
is like crazy I don't know a dog that
knows how to understand bartering and
like taking money and only money to not
anything else but I believe it when I
see a video of her grabbing a dollar out
of her jar herself and give it to him
and then get to get the treat and it
leaves the dollar there like she always
has a toy and some bills in your mouth
damn I think money everywhere she goes
but like she learned though over time
she learned that bills that are wet or
like they're ripped up that they're
useless so she can't use them so now she
takes care of the bills actually makes
sure that they're good the dog has a
[ __ ] purple hat and grills the money
to keep it nice and crisp and [ __ ] yeah
she filed taxes for that I know she has
$87 to me oh damn that's more than a lot
of people Instagram oh oh right
I thought you gonna say it's more than a
lotta Instagram oh yeah when I saw this
I like black labs because me no to that
yeah that's looking adorable it is labs
have the cutest eyes damn my dogs are
stupid they don't do [ __ ] well they
don't they don't steal your money well
cute thing that Fonda's now she's she's
like really protective over Tyga
or our son so then like I'll be holding
him and then it's
she cries she comes over she's nitride
is everything cool and then she notices
everything's good initial leave or I'll
go like you're falling and I give her um
his hand and then she comes and she like
looks at everything like this is mine or
just not anything I'm gonna eat them
when you're not looking but no no no
whenever anyone comes in they're also
protective with me I start barking
immediately I'm like you know me stop
barking at me
yeah pretty dope cute see they are smart
I want to teach him [ __ ] useless
tricks I said I want them in no tricks
criminal yeah that's what you want they
start from other people instead of
barking at people when they come in
steal their wallet yeah like a ferret
affair that's so specific they train
they train them to steal stuff what oh
really yeah weirdo monkeys doing that I
want to write Kuna do that let me know
their people are already afraid of
raccoons oh they really have a bad rap
yeah see ferret is smart monkey we
expect stealing all right very smart we
already know monkey especially with that
little hat in that [ __ ] jukebox you
already know as soon as I see those
[ __ ] I'm like mmm where's my wallet
at we're gonna steal your heart they're
gonna start marching all the monkeys are
gonna protest now like we're not in his
head yeah cuz everyone's kind of
discriminating like every time they see
a [ __ ] monkey they're like you
[ __ ] chimp
lock the doors yeah they're locking
their doors like scary movies
what did it isn't that it [ __ ] where's
the [ __ ] monkeys I don't know that
you did know know them they usually have
the Jew bargain and they have like a
yeah and there's like a fat Romanian guy
with a curly mustache that's always
controlling them and [ __ ] what you never
see that yeah like in the 30 yeah
throw back you know when you go to the
[ __ ] circus and you see the bearded
lady and the tallest man on earth
sixty isn't it funny like the [ __ ] that
used to wow people back then
it's like ladies and gentlemen this
creature has come from far away and it's
like a [ __ ] it's a little person yeah
yeah it's just it's just normal like a
giraffe or something and it was like mmm
oh my god I've never seen nothing like
it
yeah they don't travel they're all in
them yeah there's no you don't see [ __ ]
no no I'm not a pet guy what I can't
because you're not a pack because you
can't those are different um a little
bit of both we can't trust people that
don't like dogs and this sir no no no I
like dogs but I wouldn't have one
because I can't
dogs need a lot I feel like any pattern
is like I don't have a lot to give so
then it's like you're an [ __ ] you
have this pet that's getting no
attention so I just I let them do this
they're like I like that yeah you're
like if you can't give it a hundred
percent you don't commit to it yeah yeah
that's cool
I like dogs I'm not a huge fan of cats I
like those cats they're easier to take
care of them
dog them but they they do this massage
they always use the claw you know you
talking [ __ ] behind their back I didn't
start talking [ __ ] they started doing
that my first pet was a Katt Williams
cool and then they started doing that
[ __ ] I see how it will start talking
[ __ ] monkey in my eyes they steal hey
guys thanks for watching that last
episode did you love it
yes you did so don't forget to subscribe
if it's the first time you're here
we've upload every single day so don't
miss an upload now to watch more
episodes check them out up here
[Music]